okay  this is for merry christmas  no this is your welcome to america  present  okay  [Music]  why the hell would i get you a cat  forgot six  kishi keys  is just a little stuff  and that's for later  wow that's for christmas morning  [Music]  for dodgy presents  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  i wanted to give you a present and i  don't want you to have my location  anymore so  hmm i can have two motives to do that  i'll stay at this  well  then don't take the phone  i won't  look  all the time your location  i know  but isothermy  to anxiety a mole  it feels bad when you know i'm with  somebody and they're you know the love  of my life  and they don't trust me  it doesn't feel good  so why  tell me  why i don't trust you  because i spoke to a girl huh  after we were together it was in the  very beginning  i think it's different like when you  kiss a girl between have sex with a girl  [Music]  you